good morning believe nation today's
message is have a vision over you en la
been set without vision the people
perish when I say vision I'm not talking
about an outer gazing I'm talking about
an inner knowing where you allow the
dreams and the hopes and the Imaging's
to play out in your mind you must have a
vision for your life so that you don't
get sidetracked by things and people
that are not going in the direction that
you're gonna write it out and then
imagine it feel it allow the vision to
grow and I always say that when you have
a vision it means that you are pregnant
with possibility and this is the one
time when men can get pregnant because
in order to achieve what you want to
achieve in life you really got to plan
it out mentally before you do it like if
you if you look at some of the people
who accomplished some of the most
impossible tasks it would have been
impossible without huge huge vision that
they had I mean take Martin Luther King
for example he had a vision for equality
at the time it was thousand insane
vision no one would have ever thought
that we would have equality between the
black people in the white
America but today is almost that that
type of racism is completely absurd
nowadays and it would have not been
possible he hadn't even had him to
pursuit that vision and director pursue
a vision we must come up with the first
so that's why having a vision really
important I like it guys in high school
I like it I think as entrepreneurs we're
really good at having vision just I
think in general I think entrepreneurs
have a vision for something that we want
to create we see the world a different
way we're typically good at that I think
the key thing that separates it is
actually believing in the vision and
actually believe in that you can make
that world happen you may wake up in one
day you feel like super motivated super
public this is what I'm gonna do and
then the next day you wake up in it's
like oh I can't do that that's way too
big and so believing in that feeling in
like it can actually happen it's
something that's really hard to do like
feeling in your heart and knowing that
something is going to happen before it
actually happens when everybody around
you says that it's not gonna happen
you're the crazy one
you're the crazy person on the sidelines
thinking like why am I so different than
everybody else like even as I make these
YouTube videos that we're doing it on
our own that sells a headquarters dude
in them all those people walking by down
on the side this is going to get to the
point where there's there's gonna be an
audience here right I already see it
happen to people lining up every week
waiting to watch the show now there's
nobody right like people are watching in
and looking at what are these crazy
people doing what it's gonna be there
right
I'm allowed to do that one go yeah well
I know that because he was walking back
from school going to the store next door
and said hey I know you from YouTube
right so it's like it's starting but
it's gonna be much bigger in fact if I
talk about that then people think I
you're crazy I was never gonna happen
right Taylor Swift is gonna come to a
salsa class with us here at kind of
dance house right I agree that's never
gonna happen
but I believe it like this is going to
happen I'm gonna will it into existence
this is what entrepreneurs do and so I
think I think most people may not be
great at having a vision for their lives
in terms of like general public I think
entrepreneurs with a sub-segment where
we we do have a vision of something
wanna create but I think it's in just
fully believing in it breathing in
actually understand that this is
something that will happen even though
nobody else thinks that it can't happen
I think that's the difference when you
get to that point where it doesn't
matter what anybody else says you just
know what's gonna happen and you're
gonna make it happen
that's when it actually starts to happen
you don't just wish for it to happen it
actually becomes a reality exactly I
think most people don't realize that you
can mold your life instead of just
asking permission what you can do
whether it's getting a job getting
married and anything else you really
have control of your life high school I
love it so the course of the day today
is what is your vision what do you want
to achieve with the next one two three
whatever you want to call it leave it
below I like it leave in the comments or
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching and have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shut
up and spread